I remember watching nightmare in Elm
Street and your performance was so like
I was just talking to Michael Bean you
know Michael Bean yeah and I was talking
to him and I was like I remember certain
actors the movie stars where their
performances were so subtle and real and
not trying and they just seem like a
real person and when I watched you in
Nightmare it just was you brought this
grounded if it weren't for you as the
lead I mean Wes really knocked it out of
the park because it was like if you
would have got some known actress or it
could have been completely but the fact
that this is innocent girl next door
kind of but real like an actor like I
really felt like you weren't trying you
were just being and what a compliment
thank you well I swear I mean that I
think everyone thought that I think
that's why it's still ranks as one of
the best movies ever I mean nightmare El
street is one of the best ever that's
why it's right across from you and
that's not intentional well Wes you know
wrote such a great script because I
don't know how he had this ability but
he was probably 40 at the time maybe
when he did Nightmare on Elm Street but
he just had this way of getting the
lingo and the way that kids talk to each
other it wasn't perfect because there
were some lines I remember we rolled our
eyes like oh come on Wes kids don't talk
this way but in general there was this
casual back and forth that was really
you know great that's why I was such a
good writer
and a lot of his movies you can same
with Dream Warriors there's this
casualness between the patients in the
hospital that it's real and and I think
that's why that movie too is so popular
with kids I think that's the second best
one of all yeah don't you yeah people
aren't trying to get out information
you're not trying and so as an actor you
just you know I was as close to Nancy as
I possibly could have been you know and
and and I have a feeling Wes saw that in
me and he he he's like well let's just
match this girl who seems to be just
like Nancy and and we were very similar
people how
many how many auditions did you have for
that um I think two one with Wes yeah
one just a reading and then one with Wes
I mean they didn't have a budget man
they didn't have any money so I think
that it was just like we're gonna we're
going to pick 10 girls and then Wes will
come in and he'll pick the the lead it
wasn't let's move on you know we're not
going to be labor this I remember it was
only two weeks like from the first
audition to getting the part but I
remember but my point was about saying
how grounded you were and how subtle and
it just felt like a movie star I felt
like I just like I'm I'm shocked that
like the offers weren't flooding